en corse bien sûr c'est le soulagement
qui prédomine et l'on se félicite que
l'anc est enfin abouti notamment au sein
du manifeste pour la vie un mouvement
lancé par les femmes corse au lendemain
de l'assassinât de claude erignac
dans la famille nationaliste en revanche
on reste discret certains s'interrogent
même aujourd'hui sur les aveux du
commando hier à paris des réactions
réunis par alain chabod la corse comme
bien souvent partagés entre scepticisme
affiché et incrédulité murmuré face à
une enquête qui traînait les pieds face
au coup de filet qui longtemps s'étaient
multipliés jusqu'à ce dénouement soudain
en pleine crise des paillotes
ici pourtant chacun reste prudent comme
les militants du manifeste pour la vie
qui avait rassemblé contre la violence
quarante mille personnes dans les rues
d'ajaccio et de bastia au lendemain de
l'assassinât du préfet s'il est avéré
que le meurtre du préfet erignac était
lucide et nous espérons que toute la
vérité sera faite là-dessus mais nous
espérons aussi que c'est le début d'une
nouvelle pratique que l'on élucidera les
autres meurtres qui nous on tombait en
deuil et ces dernières années que l'on
ira au bout des enquêtes financières
je crois que c'est à cette seule
condition que la corse va sortir du
trouble et de l'ornière côté politique
la droite aux commandes dans l'île
attend que justice soit faite dit elle
pour se déterminer pleinement et le camp
nationaliste divisés sur le recours à la
violence condamne si elle est avérée une
telle dérive d'anciens militants
nous sommes tristes de voir une telle
radicalisation a pu avoir lieu et nous
disons qu il faut à tout prix dégager
une ligne politique majoritaire pour
éviter que ce genre d'opération il à
faire une affaire dont chacun ici attend
les suites judiciaires avec une
attention soutenue pour la ligne de
défense encore trouble qui sera celle
des accusés le démentent